um for you man like I know you uh you
and uh D smoke uh partnered up in bought
Broadway gym D smoke
um I've heard you've been doing other
stuff in the real estate game yeah yeah
I just got a house new crib yeah are you
doing anything uh are you just
everything like all that [__] for me to
move in just got finished so all the
little work that I had to do and [__] so
I'm feeling good about that I was gonna
say are you like diving in pretty pretty
tough on the real estate in terms of
just like investing no I ain't gonna sit
here in front like that but if an
opportunity present itself right and
then at the time if I got the the liquid
to do it then I'll do it but um I'm
really just focused on on music Club
just getting my brand together and
content I want to get into these movies
hey for real you think you could act I
definitely can act I did a few roles and
[__] um you know the movie [__] it's
this term that got called hurry up and
wait
so I didn't shot some [__] like a year
ago some two years ago they still ain't
releasing yeah like to be [__]
yeah yeah yeah well one of them is like
an actual feature film oh fire yeah you
think you're they're gonna Typecast you
I'm pretty Typecast but it's like some
19 shot I think I spoke on them before
on here I'm like it's in the 70s when
hip-hop first started so I'm like a
[__]
like a gangster security do they have to
cover your your tats up yeah they make
up me down
did that what's that like like seeing
yourself without tattoos for like a
couple of days
that [__] is dope like I'm gonna I
actually want to get some of this [__]
removed but I just got something on my
face
which the you know the ideal behind that
is I'm building this company up to sell
it for 100 million so when I get that
check I'm getting this [__] removed the
blue t-shirt mm-hmm
which which tattoo would you get removed
first
um by the way that [__] hurts
I don't know I gotta I like I got a lot
of [__] like I was like a scratch paper
at one time letting my homies practice
on me and [__] so you're a BG tattoo how
painful was that because it's like all
just dark ink
um it actually wasn't that painful
because the only thing that I remember
that always stand out is when you start
getting under the armpit I'm like bro
don't worry about that they ain't gonna
see you under my [__] anyway that [__]
hurts yeah it's like kind of like the
places you can't see that usually hurt
the most yeah yeah that's yeah I have a
few tattoos in
like right here that [__] hurt yeah I
want to get a few more like at first it
was like damn I want to act but now with
this makeup [__] and Technology I'm good
I wanted to I actually wanted to get
permanent gold teeth right I've been
wanting to do that since I was like 15.
and um it's like I wanted that's one
thing that's definitely you still want
to do that yeah but don't do that bro
but it's gonna be difficult you know
getting rolls because I would love to
[__] do some [__] like iced tea play
a [__] cop or just kidding just get
the drawing you popping and you pop out
yeah yeah
get this stuff all right listen I don't
know anybody who got permanents that are
like that breath don't smell like [__]
all their breath stinks and nobody
actually feels like it was a good idea
like two years later right you gotta
brush your teeth like like it's just so
much it's just a lot of Maintenance it's
a lot of [__] maintenance you could
go to Mexico and get that [__] though
done for the low ski for sure let's go
to TJ I don't want to come back with no
big horse gold teeth though you look
like A.D but we'll go see
hey do you got them Chompers hey I got
my teeth my teeth blew out right but
it's like
I feel like
if I get like a perfect set of whites it
kind of steal from the characteristics
of my [__] you know
yeah it was look like yeah I like the
Crooked chip tooth Brown tooth smile
[__] it I'm thugging it is what I didn't
live the life that lets you know some
[__] didn't happen I love it